170 millionen teilchen weltraumschrott eine riesige gefahr wir haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet unzählige herumfliegende teile die eine
gigantische zerstörungskraft haben und jetzt gibt es eine neue
Beobachtungstechnik aus deutschland was destra kann und wie uns dieses radar vor verheerenden kollisionen schützen soll jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die aktuelle bedrohungslage ist groß 60 jahre raumfahrt haben ihre spuren hinterlassen
trümmerteile ausgebrannte raketenstufe oder defekte satelliten das sind die teile beispielsweise es gibt schätzungen nach denen mehr als
20.000 objekte mit einem durchmesser von mindestens zehn zentimetern
Um unseren planeten kreisen und zwar unkontrolliert und rund
750.000 kleinere müll teilchen die etwa ein zentimeter groß sind und von der erde aus nicht
Zu erkennen sind die kommen dazu, mit. Jedem fitzelchen sind es sogar rund
170 millionen teilchen eine riesige belohnung für die etwa 1500 aktive satelliten die wir derzeit
Im weltraum haben doch nicht nur die riesige menge an weltraumschrott
2700 tonnen andere schätzungen sprechen sogar von
6500 tonnen sondern vor allem die hohe geschwindigkeit der teilchen die ist extrem gefährlich schneller als eine gewehrkugel
rasen sie durchs all
Selbst die kleinsten müll kollisionen können verheerende folgen mit sich bringen treffen sie beispielsweise auf satelliten module kommt es zur korrosion
die
vorzeitige alterung der getroffenen module ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten doch das ist noch nicht einmal der worst case denn selbst schrott teilchen von einem zentimeter
Größe können satelliten auf einen schlag komplett zerstören das hat direkte folgen für unser leben auf der erde
denn nicht zuletzt brauchen wir funktionierende satelliten um zu telefonieren wetter vorherzusagen oder uns mit dem navi von a nach b zu
Bewegen und. Im weltraum gibt es eben nun mal keine
Straßenverkehrsordnung oder polizei dafür aber jede menge geisterfahrer das einzige. Also was bleibt ist den, weltraumschrott ganz genau zu beobachten
Dafür gibt es radar die schrott teilchen werden damit vor einer möglichen kollision, aus gemessen so dass ein gefährdeter satellit
beispielsweise rechtzeitig umgelenkt werden kann aber nicht alle müll teilchen können damit
identifiziert und beobachtet werden sie sind eine riesige gefahr und können dass kessler syndrom auslösen
Dass unsere zivilisation um jahrzehnte zurückwerfen würde das kessel syndrom
startet durch einen crash innerhalb von stunden werden ein großteil der satelliten rund um die erde zerstört
inklusive der internationalen raumstation iss immer wieder schlittern wir an dieser katastrophe vorbei es gab bereits 200 kollisionen
Im arbeit der erde und jede produziert wieder neue schrott teilchen inzwischen geht man von etwa
170 millionen trümmer teilchen aus die um die erde stören wir sind quasi
Im moment zeuge eines kessler syndroms in zeitlupe spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der iridium 33 das iridium
satellitentelefon netzes gewicht eine halbe tonne und der russische satellit cosmos
zusammen bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund 40000 kilometern pro stunde bleiben von beiden satelliten nichts mehr übrig außer rund
100.000 schrott teilchen sie haben jetzt die chance für den nächsten unfall deutlich erhöht um sie zu beobachten gibt es rava
stationen auf der erde und die usa sind damit etwa 30 stationen
ganz weit vorne und von denen sind wir hier in deutschland auch abhängig der großteil der satelliten und trümmerteile
Des weltraums sind in einem öffentlichen fest katalog festgehalten doch es gibt auch welche die geheim sind
Deutschland hat jetzt nachgezogen um diese unter anderem zu finden denn auch wir sollten in der lage sein den schrott
Im weltraum zu überwachen und zu beobachten dazu haben das deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt und die luft verfallen
experimentelles überwachungs radar konstruiert sein name gäste das steht für german
experimente surveillance and tracking jordan mit ihm sollen die bahnen von satelliten und trümmerteilen in 500 bis 1200 kilometern
Höhe erfasst werden es besteht aus einem empfänger und einem sender der gepulste signale in dem weltraum schickt in vier kilometern
Höhe verdichten sich diese signale zu einem netz und das macht es möglich die müll stücke die hindurch fliegen zu
Identifizieren die empfänger auf der erde analysiert die daten und so kann die flugbahn der müll teilchen
vorhergesagt werden und satelliten können dann einer kollision ausweichen auch bei geheimen
teilchen geßler passt in einen 16 kubikmeter großen container das heißt dass ranner ist auch mobil einsetzbar
2018 soll der testbetrieb anlaufen zudem soll gestern demnächst mit dem weltraum rada tyra vom deutschen fraunhofer
institut in wachtberg kooperieren nicht nur die beteiligten forschungsteam setzen viel hoffnung in gestratz
Gerald braun vom deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt in bonn sagt zum einen fangen wir an einen deutschen bahn laden
von weltraum trümmern aufzubauen
den brauchen wir zivil und militärisch sagt braun
Denn bislang müsse auf amerikanische daten zurückgegriffen werden zum anderen sei gestern auch ein prototyp
Um gezielt die forschung für künftige weltraum beobachtungen zu fördern wenn ihr kein video zum thema, weltraumschrott und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann tut mir ja kein abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt droht mit noch mehr infos zum drohnen kessler syndrom
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran